alerta en una de las playas más
turísticas de mexico ante la fuerza con
que se moviliza el huracán agatha las
autoridades marcaron la franja costera
como una zona crítica los hoteles
albergan a los turistas mientras que
protección civil habilitó otros para los
residentes se cuenta hasta el momento
con 203 refugios habilitados para 26 mil
2 806 personas
principalmente las zonas afectadas son
desde el este del istmo de tehuantepec
hasta el oeste de puerto escondido y
desde salinas cruz hasta barra de tonalá
en chiapas los habitantes de la costa
reforzaron sus viviendas además se
abastecieron de alimentos y agua los
puertos marítimos fueron cerrados y las
aerolíneas cancelaron sus vuelos en el
aeropuerto internacional de huatulco era
necesario proteger todas las partes
vulnerables sólo de todo donde había
edificios con cristales
y ahorita estamos protegiendo todo sobre
todo los que viene de parte de la playa
el país es constantemente atacado por
los huracanes en los meses de mayo y
noviembre la mayor preocupación de las
autoridades son las inundaciones
repentinas y los deslizamientos de
tierra agatha es el primer huracán de la
temporada del pacífico oriental